well thank you for joining us here at
noon i'm heather mills an early morning
fire sent a large plume of smoke over
the valley you may have seen it it
started about 6 30 on paradise just
north of sahara and it's not the first
time they've had to put out a fire at
that same location that's where hector
mahia joins us live in hector at this
moment any
word on what caused it
no updates yet on the cost but we're
told when firefighters arrived they
found a car on fire behind the building
here's a look at what's left crews right
now fencing off the property there were
no initial reports that anyone was
trapped inside but firefighters are
checking just to make sure
for more than two hours at paradise and
sahara thursday morning yolanda coleman
lives nearby and says these fires are
happening way too often too many to
count actually two minutes to count i
just pray that no one is actually inside
since it is a place that the homeless
people normally go through to try to
seek shelter the first calls came in
just before 6 30 this morning this is
the source of that large plume of smoke
seen all across the valley this morning
we've learned it's not the first time
firefighters have responded to this
building in fact clark county deputy
fire chief thomas touchstone says they
put out multiple small fires here before
it's had squatters in it with lots of
hoarding conditions and previous fires
the city of las vegas recently passed an
ordinance to try and deal with vacant
properties that put people at risk these
buildings are often hotbeds for criminal
activity and fires they do have a
program where they tear down structures
like this after there's been multiple
fires once the structure becomes
hazardous to people
then they go ahead and tear it down
so they work with the property owners to
make sure that it gets demolished
now you're taking a look at the front
entrance to this building that just
shows you some of the last some of the
mess left behind inside and we are told
just about 50 firefighters worked this
fire reporting live near saharan
paradise hector mejia live local now